the other takeaway I have is on the
topic of hate
I think all humans have the capacity
almost an animalistic craving for hate
of the other the enemy whether it's
individuals like Emmanuel Goldstein or
nations like Eurasia and East Asia which
I should say are the two other super
States
describe in this book that are
constantly at war with each other again
the fascinating thing about the way this
book is written is you don't know if
Eurasia or East Asia exists you really
don't know what exists or what is true
beyond the local little interaction
local little world of the main character
and that I think is the point when you
don't really know there's no steady
footing on which to uh
construct a world view from which you
can have hope about a better future
that longing for a better future
and so this animalistic uh craving for
hate or the capacity to have hate
especially when we're in crowds I think
is most
uh
powerfully Illustrated in the two
minutes of hate which is practiced by
the society and the quote is
the horrible thing about the two minutes
of hate was not that one was obliged to
act apart
but that it was impossible to avoid
joining in within 30 seconds any
pretense was always unnecessary a
hideous Ecstasy of fear and
vindictiveness a desire to kill to
torture to smash faces in with a
sledgehammer seemed to flow through the
whole group of people like an electric
current turning one even against one's
will into a grimacing screaming lunatic
and yet the rage that one felt was an
abstract undirected emotion which could
be switched from one object to another
like the flame of a blow lamp
that's the point
is you get the crowd together you get
them to hate Goldstein or Eurasia or
East Asia you get them to hate anything
and because that that feeling that drug
that hypnotic uh
isn't that mass hypnosis that you feel
can be directed by the state into any
direction and because you have complete
control of History you can direct it on
a day-by-day basis towards any Target
and as long as the hate
is catalyzed to these kinds of rituals
as long as the hate is there
it can overpower the individualistic
feeling of love we have for each other
so that that hate
is a more animalistic desire I don't
know what to make of it
of course it's also important to say
that this book I think I've read many
places that it was an intended
originally by Orwell as a satire
although satire that has quite a lot of
torture at the end and uh doesn't seem
to have much humor but
I think if you read it as a satire
that's the way
it's better to understand its relevance
in our society today because a lot of
things like two minutes of hate is
almost like a caricature of what hate
looks like in a mass Gathering
but if you take it as a caricature it
can now reveal you some of the elements
that already exist in human nature that
are there and that we should be very
cautious about so it reveals the very
thing that if not
monitored by ourselves
can result in a slippery slope that
leads to
um yeah destruction of uh the tribalism
destruction of other groups and then
control of the
collective intelligence of our species
through the totalitarian state
I think there's elements of this that
are just under illustration
in social media today I don't want to
overstate it I think just like comparing
things to Hitler comparing things to
1984 I think is a reach in most cases
but social media does reveal this kind
of mass hysteria this capacity of humans
to be outraged of outrage based on
tribalism
so we have to understand it we have to
resist giving into it on the individual
level and I do believe
we have the responsibility to create
technology that helps us resist it that
incentivizes us not to be cruel to each
other just because all the people in
whatever tribe we Define ourselves in
are being cruel to a particular person
or a particular group